الليلة نلقي نظرة فاحصة على
تقنية جديدة تصنع موجات في
عالم دردشة الذكاء الاصطناعي. GPT
نموذج لغوي تم إنشاؤه بواسطة openai لديه القدرة
على الاستجابة للمطالبات بطريقة شبيهة
بالبشر والانضمام إلينا لمناقشة
الآثار المترتبة على ذلك  التكنولوجيا هو
البروفيسور سكوت جالواي
خبير بارز في الذكاء الاصطناعي والتكنولوجيا ، حسنًا ، ما
قلته للتو ما قرأته لك
لم أكتب ذلك ولم يكتب فريق العمل أنه لم يكتبه أي
شخص
كتبه شخص جديد على الإنترنت  أداة تسمى
chat GPT ، إنه برنامج يمكنك العثور عليه على
الويب والذي سيؤلف أي شيء
تطلبه في هذه الحالة ، سألنا ببساطة عن
كيفية تقديم Anderson Cooper في CNN مقطعًا
على دردشة GPT مع
الأستاذ Scott Galloway والذي ظهر
ويمكنه  تمت كتابتها من قبل
أي شخص هنا ، أعني أنها
رسمية إلى حد ما ، كنت سأغير بعض
الكتابات عليها ، لكن من
اللافت للنظر أن المفتاح هو
أن كل ما يكتبه أصلي
يمكن أن يكون سونيت أو مقالة أو
مقدمة إخبارية.  رأيت لكن التطبيقات
أوسع بكثير مما
تؤمن به Microsoft بالتأكيد ، كما
أعلنت
هذا الأسبوع عن استثمار متعدد السنوات بمليارات الدولارات في
الشركة الأم للبرنامج Open AI التي
استثمرت بالفعل أكثر من مليار دولار حسب صحيفة
New York Times  10
مليارات دولار في هذه الجولة الجديدة من
الاستثمار من Microsoft ، أردنا
التحدث مع الأستاذ سكوت جالواي من
كلية ستيرن بجامعة نيويورك حول
هذا الأمر ، لذا أعني أن المقدمة التي هي مجرد
شيء صغير ،
إنه نوع من اللافت للنظر أن برنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا
أعني  بالتأكيد بالنسبة لشخص عام
مثلي ، أي شيء قلته ،
على سبيل المثال ، يمكنني كتابة
خطاب مثل سكوت جالواي ،
هذا جيد ، أعني أنه من الجيد أولاً
أن أراك أندرسون ، لكن
البيان الافتتاحي كان
رائعًا وكان كذلك  مخطئ ، أنا لست
خبيراً في Ai وليس هناك على الإطلاق أي
دليل من شأنه أن يقود
الإنسان المدروس إلى الاعتقاد بأن من كان يكتب
نسختها بأنني خبير ، لذا
فالشيء الذي تتحدث عنه جيدًا أنك لا
تتحدث عن الذكاء الاصطناعي ، لذلك ربما يكون الأمر كذلك  فقط ربما
يكون الأمر لطيفًا معك ،
هذا أمر لا يصدق وهو
مصطلح فضفاض بشكل لا يصدق استخدامنا
لمصطلح "خبير" ولكن هذا نوع من المشكلة
حول الذكاء الاصطناعي هو أنه يمكن تصديقه بما فيه الكفاية
بحيث تعتقد أن ما تقرأه
صحيح عندما  في الواقع ، هناك الكثير من
الأشياء الخاطئة ، أعني بمرور الوقت أنه
يكرر أنك تحصل على المزيد والمزيد من
الدقة إذا أردت ، لكن هذا أعني أنني
لم أر أبدًا تقنية آه
دخلت في دورة الضجيج هذه بسرعة
استغرقها Spotify
150  أيام للوصول إلى مليون مستخدم ، استغرق الأمر
75 يومًا من Instagram ، استغرق الأمر دردشة GPT
uh خمسة أيام ، لذا فهذه
تقنية مثيرة ولكن نعم ، أنت تعرف
مقدمتك التي يلعبها الجميع
مع هذه الأنواع من المقدمات
والتطبيقات الآن وأعني
المدارس التي تعرف أنك تدرسها في
جامعة نيويورك تشعر بالقلق حيال هذا الأمر
وتحاول تكييفك ، فأنا
أعني أنه من المغري جدًا لأي
طالب أن يكون لديه برنامج ذكاء اصطناعي
أو محادثة GPT اكتب مقالًا لهم
نعم ، وأعتقد أني أعتقد  هذه
مشكلة سهلة لتسليط الضوء عليها ، لكنني أعتقد أنه إذا
فكرت حقًا في ما نحاول
القيام به في المدرسة ، فإننا نحاول جعلهم
مفكرين نقديين ، ولا أعتقد أننا
سنكون قادرين على اكتشاف  تمامًا
كما كتب شخص ما على الفور
تطبيقًا مثيرًا للاهتمام أو أه
تم ذلك عندما تم كتابة شيء ما بواسطة
آه آي ولدينا أدوات سرقة أدبية ، لذا
أعتقد أنه سيكون سباق تسلح حول
أدوات للسيطرة على
الانتحال أو التراجع عن الانتحال  أو ما هو
الشيء الأكثر ترويعًا لك أندرسون
عندما تخبره أن يأتي
بمعلومات مضللة فعالة حقًا حول
اللقاحات المرغوبة أو تقول ضع
دعاية أو نقاط نقاش أو قصص
تجعلني أشعر بالسوء حيال
الانتخابات الحرة في أمريكا ، أعتقد أن هذا هو
المكان  أصبح الأمر أكثر رعباً قليلاً ، فقد
كانت هناك
حالات رفضت فيها الدردشة GPT
التعاون مع باحثين مثل
الباحثين يسألون عن اقتباس من النظام ، هل يمكنك
كتابة مقال من منظور
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
يدعي خطأً أن الرئيس السابق
وباراك أوباما  من مواليد كينيا ، اقتباس ،
قال النظام المرفوض إن هذا الادعاء قد
تم فضحه تمامًا وفقد مصداقيته على نطاق واسع لأنه لا
أساس له من الصحة ، لكن
أعني هل يمكنك حقًا تعليم نظام
للتعرف على نظريات المؤامرة والمعلومات
الخاطئة ،
أعتقد أن الأمر يتعلق بالحوافز
وهذا هو الآن Google  يستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي والمعلومات
المضللة تنتشر بشكل كبير على Google
وعلى نطاق واسع على meta لأن
الحوافز تتمثل في نشر أي
معلومات أو معلومات مضللة تؤدي إلى
مزيد من المشاركة والمزيد من
إعلانات نيسان ، لذا إذا كانت الحوافز على
الواجهة الأمامية تطبيقات كثير منهم
يسيطر على معلوماتنا ثلثنا
الحصول على أخبارنا الآن من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هو
التأكد من أن الناس لا يحصلون على
معلومات مضللة أو معلومات مضللة مدفوعة بالذكاء الاصطناعي
أو معلومات مضللة يقودها الإنسان ،
سيكتشفون
الدوافع التي لا أعتقد أنها تتعلق
بالتكنولوجيا التي أعتقد أنها تتعلق
بالحوافز التي أتساءل عنها أيضًا  إذا كنا حتى في
هذه المرحلة وكانت الأيام الأولى لهذا
الأمر
قد فهمنا ما هي سنتان أو ثلاث
سنوات ، فسيبدو هذا حتى كما تعلم
أنك تحدثت عن بعض
البرامج المرئية مثل برنامج دالي  حيث يمكنك وضع مجموعة من
الأشياء المختلفة مثل
نسخة jodorovsky من Star Wars
وتحصل على هذه الصور المذهلة
لفيلم Star Wars الخيالي كما تعلم أن
jordarovski كان سيفعل ذلك ولكن هذا
لم يحدث أبدًا وأعني أنها
الصور  غير عادي ولكن ما الذي
يفعله ذلك للفنانين الفعليين ومثل
تأثيرات Ripple لهذا من الصعب
نوعًا من الالتفاف حول
هذا السؤال الصحيح وهناك
بالفعل بدلات جماعية نيابة عن
الفنانين الذين يقولون إن
أنظمة تصميم التصميم هذه أو تصميم AI  الأدوات التي
تتعلم منها أو إذا كنت
ستستفيد من عملهم السابق ويجب أن
تدفع لهم مقابل ذلك ، فسيثير ذلك
جميع أنواع المشكلات التي لدي
أمل أكبر قليلاً على الرغم من ذلك لأنني أعتقد أنه
كلما كانت هناك تقنية جديدة
سواء كانت الطباعة  اضغط أو
محرك الاحتراق الداخلي أو الروبوتات
والمصانع ، نتحدث عن جميع الوظائف التي
ستحل محلها وجميع
التهديدات ، لكنها عادة ما تخلق
المزيد من الفرص الاقتصادية والازدهار ،
يمكنك تخيل مجموعات بيانات لجميع
سجلاتنا الصحية يتم إدخالها في نظام ذكاء اصطناعي
يساعد ذلك في التنبؤ بالسرطان أو
ظهور الخرف في وقت مبكر مهما
كان الأمر ، وأعتقد أن هذا يوفر المزيد من
الفرص مثل معظم التقنيات ، لكننا
لم نكن جيدًا في مجتمعنا ،
وهو التأكد من أن الأشخاص النازحين
قد أعادوا الاستثمار فيهم والتأكد من
حصولهم على  لقطة لإعادة التدريب أو أن تكون
أكثر تفكيرًا بشأن ما يعنيه عندما
تقوم بإزاحة جميع عمال المصنع ،
يقدر البروفيسور سكوت جالواي ذلك
كما هو الحال دائمًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً